[Musica]
Buonasera Barletta e per me è un
grandissimo piacere essere qui con voi
il cappello bicorno che vedete qui con
me è una Feluca è il simbolo della
diplomazia e appartenuto a un
diplomatico del Regno d'Italia Come si
può dedurre dal bottone che porta il
motto di casa Savoia fert Fortitudo
elius rodum tenuity la sua forza
preserverà Rodi bene È un bell'oggetto
mi piaceva mostrarvelo Io sono un
Ambasciatore della Repubblica Italiana
ho servito il mio paese per più di 38
anni e come sapete sono di Barletta la
diplomazia muta a che fare con il tema
di questo incontro tensione a dir la
verità io ho pensato di ritrovare il mio
intervento
ipertensione non sarebbe stato fuori
luogo perché sono tante lezioni sulla
scena internazionale Ma voi alcuni amici
hanno detto Guarda che con la sua età
Qualcuno potrebbe pensare che vuoi
parlare dei problemi di salute della
terza età quindi ho cambiato
Ho fatto una scelta diversa e mi sono
ricordato di una frase scritta sui muri
dell'università
grande la confusione sotto il cielo la
situazione Dunque eccellente una frase
attribuita da alcune a Confucio da altre
morse tu credo che Massimo D'Alema ci
abbia scritto anche un libro e credo che
catturi il momento nel quale viviamo
stasera vorrei raccontarvi dei grandi
cambiamenti della nostra società quelli
che vengono definiti i mega trans le
mega tendenze
cambiamenti climatici rivoluzione
digitale migrazioni
climatici e transizione energetica sono
due aspetti intrinsecamente legati i
dati e gli effetti dell'emergenza
climatica Ormai sono sotto gli occhi di
tutti la comunità scientifica l'accordo
di Parigi hanno indicato la necessità di
stare ben al di sotto dei due gradi di
aumento la temperatura rispetto ai
livelli pre-industriali
per raggiungere Questo obiettivo il
ruolo dell'energia nella riduzione delle
missioni è fondamentale pensate
nell'Unione Europea una delle aree più
sviluppate del mondo il 75% dei gas
serra deriva dall'uso dell'energia la
matrice energetica così come l'abbiamo
conosciuta negli ultimi secoli deve
cambiare è una sfida titanica che
intende rivoluzionare come produciamo
come consumiamo energia
Ovviamente la domanda ce la possiamo
fare Sì possiamo farcela ma serve
ovviamente il contributo di tutti
l'obiettivo dell'Unione Europea è di
ridurre del 55% le missioni che a Serra
entro il 2030 e di raggiungere la nostra
realtà climatica entro il 2050 un
cambiamento radicale che va gestito Noi
stiamo parlando di una trasformazione
epocale che deve essere realizzato in un
periodo estremamente breve alcuni
attività spariranno per sempre o saranno
meno rilevanti rispetto a oggi altre
verranno create useremo di più il treno
meno l'auto andremo più in bicicletta
più elettricità prodotta da energie
rinnovabili forse nucleare anche e meno
gas e petrolio è fisiologico che si
creino tensioni in un periodo di rapida
e trasformazione
interi paesi che hanno basato il loro
sviluppo sull'uso di risorse energetiche
e fossili saranno costretti a
reinventarsi altri potranno trovare un
equilibrio Grazie all'uso di nuove
tecnologie insomma siamo in un momento
storico Dobbiamo cambiare il mondo
rendendolo più bello più pulito più
verde e più sostenibile una bella sfida
nella quale dobbiamo metterci tutta la
nostra intelligenza tutto il nostro
impegno per governare il cambiamento se
non lo faremo lo dovremo prepararci a
peggio il po' asciutto niente acqua e
regione che hanno vissuto
nell'abbondanza idrica che hanno
sviluppato economia e Civiltà basate
sull'esistenza di un fiume che potrebbe
esserci più Credo che basti per come
come esempio
il secondo grande cambiamento della
nostra esistenza è causato dalla
rivoluzione digitale vi racconta adesso
quello che mi è successo nel 1995 in
quell'anno tornavo alla Farnesina del
mio primo periodo all'estero e ricordo
un direttore generale mi chiamo e mi
disse contro uno serio Antonio abbiamo
deciso di affidarti la preparazione
della partecipazione dell'Italia a G7
sulla società dell'informazione
erano iniziative di algor destinata a
far capire quale trasformazione stava
per prodursi Con l'avvento di Internet e
della banda larga
mi fece vedere l'ufficio una stanza
enorme una mega scrivania da direttore
generale con otto zampe sapete che
l'amministrazione pubblica A seconda del
grado di tocca un tavolo con delle gambe
diverse quindi deve essere una cosa
pazzesca e guardate cosa c'era come
strumentazione tecnologica
un telefono nero di bachelite con la
rotella per fare i numeri
chiese un computer e Mi arrivò in pochi
giorni poi chiesi il collegamento
internet e lì scoppiò la crisi
a quei tempi per telefonare a Roma devi
essere abilitato e per chiamare
all'estero Dove chiedere al centralino
di passato il numero sembra un secolo fa
fu la mia prima esperienza in realtà
virtuale io devo spiegare via superiori
che non ho mai messo le mani sul
computer che cosa era internet
vi racconto questo episodio perché aiuta
a capire in pochissimo tempo l'utilizzo
delle tecnologie digitali come
l'utilizzo della tecnologia digitale
trasformato totalmente la società
modificando in modo nel quale le persone
vivono lavorano e comunicano ed è un
processo che non si arresta siamo e
saremo sempre di più in un modo digitale
e connesso non avremo nessun problema a
collegarci da qualsiasi angolo del
pianeta
12.000 mini satelliti con sterling di
Mask
3.286 satelliti con cui perdi pesos 650
satellite di One web È impressionante
migliaia e migliaia di satelliti per
consentirci una connettività ovunque
Internet of Things big data intelligenza
artificiale influenza nel mondo della
ricerca della produzione pensate
all'impatto che ha sulla medicina dalla
Diagnostica a contro dei sintomi e delle
cure all'accelerazione dei processi di
produzione dei vaccini e dei medicinali
l'impatto sul mondo del lavoro è già
enorme ma molte attività saranno ancor
più svolte dalle macchine
le trasformazioni della società saranno
radicali importanti questioni relative
alla nostra privacy alle regole di vita
Democratica ai problemi
dell'ineguaglianza e dell'inclusione
sociale si impongono con aspetti
fondamentali che la nostra società
devono affrontare la questione non è
quella di vantaggi e l'intelligenza
artificiale può portare ma quella di
tanti rischi che potremmo correre se gli
esseri umani perdessero la capacità di
essere umani Vogliamo i vantaggi della
tecnologia ma non vogliamo che qualcuno
si aspetta analizzare come vivo che
faccio cosa leggo Con chi mi vedo per
influenzare A decidere della mia vita
abbiamo bisogno di regole condivise che
ci assicurino i vantaggi e proibiscano
delle nuove tecnologie
ora la terza metà tendenza invece è
legata all'andamento demografico e alle
migrazioni a novembre sarri molto
miliardi in Italia siamo andati da
un'altra parte in controtendenza pensate
nel 2048 i decessi potrebbero essere il
doppio del rinascite
le conseguenze economiche sociali sono
evidenti ha un futuro un paese che non
si riproduce nel paese che fa della
famiglia il punto di forza di famiglia
se ne fanno sempre meno c'è qualcosa che
non va nel buio sociale di questo paese
e tutti questi anziani finiranno per
pensare al suo numero limitato di
persone che lavorano
Certo un aiuto verrà dall'emigrazione
che danno già un importante aiuto alla
vita del paese e saranno un fenomeno
difficilmente aggirabile aumenterà la
pressione dell'Africa nel 2050 un quarto
della popolazione mondiale sarà africano
quindi vivremo e società multietniche
per un Paese come l'Italia basterebbe
guardare l'esperienza passata per capire
che cosa va fatto
Quando io ho iniziato questo lavoro mi
occupavo degli italiani emigrati
all'estero la nostra preoccupazione era
quella di garantire ai nostri immigrati
di mandare i figli a scuola di lavorare
in sicurezza di vivere in condizioni
decenti di assicurare loro una pensione
ora che siamo Confrontati con
l'immigrazione sembra che non abbiamo
fatto tesoro La nostra esperienza di
quando gli Emirati eravamo noi
dobbiamo evitare che nella nostra
società si producono fratture pericolose
come successi in altri paesi ma
fatichiamo a trovare una risposta a
livello internazionale le opinioni
pubbliche dei paesi di destinazione dei
flussi migratori Hanno sviluppato una
sensibilità notevole ma di fronte alla
tragedia delle decine di migliaia di
morti nel Mediterraneo delle migliaia di
Minori abbandonati una risposta si
impone
questi tre fenomeni che vi ho descritto
investono tutte le società viviamo in un
mondo globalizzato il contributo della
diplomazia per trovare delle risposte
comuni e problemi dell'umanità è
fondamentale
le nazioni unite Hanno lanciato nel 2015
gli obiettivi di sviluppo sostenibile un
grande piano articolato 17 obiettivi che
cerca di tracciare un sentiero per la
costruzione di un mondo più giusto più
sostenibile più Democratico anche il G7
G20 e altro organizzazione regionale
partecipazioni più ristretta sono
impegnate nella ricerca di soluzioni che
vadano alla stessa direzione ma non
sempre quello che noi pensiamo e
pianifichiamo si svolge secondo lo
scenario che abbiamo immaginato eventi
imprevedibili influiscono sulla nostra
vita e sul lavoro che cerchiamo di fare
Ne Cito 2 Il covit è la guerra in
Ucraina prendiamo il caso il covip ha
stravolto le nostre assistenze tutte le
società sono state messe a dura prova a
questo ciò che abbiamo risposto con
misure incredibili eccezionali ora
abbiamo capito che situazione simili
potrebbero presentarsi in futuro
Dobbiamo rivedere il funzionamento della
sanità e il suo finanziamento guardare
alla salute degli esseri umani persone
già di per sé complessa ma anche al
mondo animale provengono i virus e le
ultime pandemie e alle condizioni
dell'ambiente al nostro pianeta
la guerra in Ucraina c'è Invece
riportato a vivere situazioni che
pensavano fossero ormai del passato la
preoccupazione è grande Io pensavo alla
storia della mia famiglia mio nonno ha
vissuto durante due guerre Mio padre ha
partecipato alla seconda guerra mondiale
e perse anche delle dita della mano a
causa di un eminanti uomo Io sono nato
nel 57 lo stesso anno nel quale veniva
creata la comunità europea sono il primo
della mia famiglia che non sa che cos'è
la guerra
i miei figli hanno conosciuto Un'Europa
senza frontiera hanno viaggiato senza
bisogno di Passaporti e senza necessità
di cambiare moneta sono i millennials
europei avete capito la storia della mia
famiglia e il Signore delle vostre
famiglie è la nostra storia quella di un
paese che sta conoscendo il periodo più
lungo di pace e di crescita del
Benessere degli ultimi secoli siamo
cresciuti pensando che la guerra non
appartenesse al nostro futuro ora ci
chiediamo se saremo in grado di
assicurare le prossime generazioni un
periodo di benessere di pace così lungo
come quello che abbiamo sperimentato
fino ad oggi
ora se queste situazioni di profonda
trasformazione la pandemia difende la
guerra noi vicine fossero state
affrontate nel nostro paese in
solitudine saremo in una situazione
sicuramente molto più difficile e invece
il fatto di essere membri dell'Unione
Europea parte di un'alleanza militare
essere un paese sviluppato inserito nei
processi di collaborazione
internazionale ci consente di affrontare
questo mare in tempesta con maggiori
garanzie
Stiamo affrontando molti cambiamenti
molto crisi Alla quale possiamo uscire
rafforzati se le scelte saranno quelle
giuste in questo è fondamentale il ruolo
dei governi nel momento in cui siamo
alle prese di questi cambiamenti epocali
emerge però in modo prepotente un
problema che ci deve far riflettere
quello della crisi di fiducia
dell'opinione pubblica dei paesi
democratici nell'operato dei governi non
sto parlando solo dell'Italia parlo di
un fenomeno più ampio che invece tutte
le società democratiche guardate questa
tabella Spero si possa vedere
questa tabella questo studio del
dell'obsen
l'opzione pubblica si fida della polizia
ma non si fida dei partiti i partiti
Sono a parte quella cercate Il rosso il
tasso di partecipazione alle elezioni si
abbassa Ora voglio dire che questa
tabella non riguarda l'Italia forse
questo non può essere una cosa
confortante Ma i sistemi democratici a
questo punto pongono Sono di fronte una
sfida riusciranno a resistere o rischio
di soccombere la democrazia Per riuscire
a dimostrare di essere superiore
all'autocrazia ora con questo
interrogativo non voglio lasciarvi una
notte insonne ma per cambiare è
necessario che ognuno di noi faccia
qualcosa si mobiliti
occorre motivare i governi ma
soprattutto partecipare la pressione
dell'opinione pubblica è fondamentale
l'esempio di Greta thunberg è indicativo
questa ragazza giovanissima è riuscita
ad avere un effetto globale ispirando
migliaia di giovani a scendere in piazza
è importante coinvolgere nuove
generazioni le scelte che stiamo
compiendo sono loro a chiedercelo e ora
di smettere di prendere decisioni che
riversano onere problemi sulle
generazioni future
questo momento di grande cambiamenti ci
regalano opportunità cruciale spetta a
tutti noi di coglierla per salvare il
mondo e dunque grande la confusione
sotto il cielo la situazione eccellente
E io sono ottimista Grazie
[Applauso]